we've all encountered that bug that made  us walk through walls or fall through  the ground but reddit user uncomfortable  NPC has taken the glitch to a whole new  level a whole new world if you will  there's an entire planet outside of  rocket leagues wasteland arena using  certain mutators uncomfortable MPC  managed to find his way outside of the  usual rocket league arena what he found  was a planet full of sand dunes in alien  architecture the question is why is this  stuff here especially if you can't see  it from inside the actual arena  developer psionics hasn't answered the  question but they have tweeted out of  tease there's still plenty of rocket  League action going on out there you can  catch up with gamespot zone tournament  on our YouTube page and for all the  updates on rocket League you're already  in the right place